[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale notre
invité aujourd'hui est Moïse Katumbi le
président d'ensemble pour la République
et avec moi pour cette interview
Christophe Bouvier de RFI Moïse Katumbi
bonjour bonjour
Pierre Leman monsieur Katumbi on va
commencer par la situation dans l'est du
pays les violences les exactions
continuent malgré les tentatives de
médiation est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec le président Félix Tshisekedi quand
il accuse son homologue rwandais Paul
Kagame d'être l'agresseur et quand il
appelle à la rescousse la Communauté des
États d'Afrique de l'Est
vous savez mes pensées vont d'abord à la
population congolaise nous avons des
milliers de milliers de déplacés des
guerres dans notre pays et je condamne
fermement cette agression du M23 vous
savez que ça soit le Rwanda ou le
Burundi ou l'Ouganda je ne serai jamais
d'accord
que de pays voisins puissent aider le
rebelle dans notre pays c'est une guerre
injuste le M23 doit partir vous savez
moi je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui pleure
ça fait depuis
1998 que nous sommes en train de
condamner condamner les autres pays
voisins
il faudrait qu'on cesse de pleurer il
faut qu'on nous puissions agir donc il
faut que nous puissions motiver notre
armée est-ce que vous donc vous opposez
à cette force d'interposition des États
d'Afrique de l'Est qui a commencé à se
déployer vous savez il y a de pays
soupçonnés chez nous il y a plus la
confiance de la population nous avons
une très bonne armée mais nos militaires
ne sont pas motivés vous savez c'est
une armée forte une armée
professionnelle nous avons de militaires
qui ont débuté les M23
ils avaient quitté
nos frontières mais le grand problème
que nous avons aujourd'hui l'armée est
démotivée moi-même lors de ma tournée à
l'Est du pays j'avais écrit au président
Tshisekedi une lettre j'avais parlé avec
lui pour dire écoutez il faudrait qu'on
améliore le salaire de militaire ils
sont démotivés et aussi il faut organise
des bonnes élections parce que vous
savez la légitimité aussi dans un pays
et doit compter et le grand problème que
nous avons aujourd'hui aussi longtemps
que nos militaires ne sont pas bien
rémunérés les social ne marchent pas et
nous allons toujours continuer à pleurer
c'est pourquoi je dis il y a moyen
d'arrêter cette guerre il faudrait avoir
une vision et il faut dire non à
l'agression alors les élections
présidentielles législatives elles sont
prévues par la CENI la commission
électorale le 20 décembre 2023
pour la plupart des observateurs
internationaux le calendrier est
matériellement intenable et un
glissement inévitable mais le président
Tshisekedi affirme que ce ne sera pas le
cas quel est votre point de vue
vous savez je me rappelle bien du
cardinal en Bongo il avait dit
d'un mal parfois on peut sortir un bien
pour le pays le d'abord
l'élection de la de Kadima a été
contestée par tout le monde le président
de le président de la de la CNI mais le
plus important pour nous c'est l'unité
et l'avenir de notre pays oublions le
passé voyons voir la la l'avenir
j'espère que Kadima sera à la hauteur
pour nous donner de bonnes élections
c'est vrai il va être très difficile
mais il reste inané si on a la volonté
de changer les choses dans notre pays
le président Kadima doit le démontrer et
en plus le le le le plus important pour
moi c'est les jours des élections je
demande à la population congolaise ils
doivent aller s'enrouler et le jour nous
allons pas permettre cette fraude les
élections chaotiques qu'on aille en 2018
je demande à la population congolaise de
faire de sacrifices pour que nous
puissions avoir de bonnes élections le
jour des élections ils doivent pas
quitter le bureau de vote mais est-ce
que l'état de siège
décréter en étouriers dans le Nord qui
vous depuis plus d'un an ne risque pas
de faire obstacle à la transparence vous
savez je veux parler de l'état de siège
humain je voulais terminer d'abord le
jour de de de de votre ils doivent pas
quitter le bureau de vote on doit
compter et afficher le résultat et nous
serons pas d'accord avec votre
électronique on sera d'accord avec le
vote et
semi électronique le tas de siège c'est
un malheur pour nous on a renouvelé
l'état de siège plus de 40 fois
aujourd'hui dans notre pays il est tas
de siège a été mal planifié malgré que
j'étais dans l'union sacrée on n'a
jamais été consulté mais cet état de
siège à créer plus de problèmes et je
crois que si on a été contacté si tout
était planifié le gouverneur de
militaire ne pouvait pas rester
à Goma on allait le mettre dans les
territoires où il y a la guerre comme ça
il allait être au front au lieu de
rester dans un bureau climatique mais
j'espère bientôt
le militaire vont tout faire pour
chasser le le
M23 dans notre pays et que nous aurons
des bonnes élections alors justement à
propos de bonnes élections
Adolphe mosito l'ancien Premier ministre
accuse la scénie de planifier une fraude
est-ce que vous aussi vous suspectez que
une fraude est en train d'être planifiée
ou est-ce que vous accordez sa chance à
la saigner encore j'accorde la chance à
la CENI la seule solution c'est la
population elle doit rester vigilante et
doit rester sur chaque bureau de vote
elle partira jamais aussi longtemps
qu'on n'a pas encore compter les voix et
afficher le résultat
jusqu'à nouvel ordre Moïse Katumbi votre
partie ensemble pour la République et
vous-même vous êtes toujours allié de
Félix Tshisekedi dans l'union sacrée
quel qu'est-ce que vous pensez quel
bilan vous portez qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la gestion du pays par le
président de shisekedi depuis 4 ans vous
savez
je suis allié dans l'union sacrée ça
fait de cela ça fait deux ans le
président Tshisekedi avait fait appel à
moi et à mon parti pour le rejoindre
mais le bilan est très mauvais le bilan
est chaotique mais j'ai donné des
conseils en interne j'ai écrit au
présent de la de la République et
j'avais aussi donné le cahier de charge
quand j'ai accepté de rejoindre l'Union
sacrée et c'est cahier des charges n'a
pas été considéré
alors depuis des mois tout le monde se
pose la question en raison de ce que
vous venez de dire de vos critiques à
l'égard du président Tshisekedi la
question est la suivante est-ce que vous
allez oui ou non être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de décembre
2023 vous savez ce n'est pas des
critiques c'est une réalité
j'ai donné de conseils
en interne mais comme la situation
continue à être chaotique je dois sauver
un peuple en danger
et je serai candidat en 2023 mais je
dois avaliser ma candidature au congrès
de notre partie le 19
à Lubumbashi donc j'essaierai candidat
parce que je une vision pour mon pays et
j'ai des j'ai un bilan quand j'étais
gouverneur et j'ai de l'expertise aussi
je ne viens pas là pour faire de
l'aventure parce que vous savez faut pas
chercher le pouvoir pour le pouvoir je
serai un président qui ne pleure pas je
serai un président qui va trouver de
solution pour son pays donc ça y est
votre décision est prise aujourd'hui
vous êtes candidat
la décision est prise je suis candidat
je suis candidat parce que j'ai une
vision j'ai un programme où
un programme où on va nous respecter ce
que je fais je vais créer de l'emploi
j'ai les infrastructures à refaire il y
a le tourisme aussi on doit aussi
reconstruire notre armée donc la
sécurité dans notre pays j'ai tout un
programme
alors cela signifie que avec votre
partie ensemble pour la République vous
allez devoir quitter l'union sacrée vous
venez de nous le dire vous allez tenir
un congrès le 19 c'est-à-dire je crois
lundi prochain ce sera où et est-ce que
surtout vous ne craignez pas que
beaucoup de vos députés
sénateurs ministres même vous avez 5
ministres actuellement dans le
gouvernement et ben ne vous abandonne
pour soutenir le candidat de shisekedi
vous savez
j'ai décidé
de quitter donc j'ai dit au revoir
à l'Union à l'union sacrée mais je dois
aussi consulter
et le membre de mon parti le lundi
au congrès à Lubumbashi je sais qu'il y
a des gens qui vont nous quitter et
c'est ça la démocratie ce qui partent
vont laisser la place aux autres mais
nous allons continuer avec de vrais
combattants qui vous qui voudront que
nous puissions changer la situation de
notre pays ensemble pour un Congo
meilleur
alors cette décision vous y avez
longtemps réfléchi parce qu'elle est
lourde de conséquences il y a quelques
jours Laurent battais Benga le président
du tribunal de commerce de Lubumbashi à
démissionné il a déclaré dans sa lettre
de démission on va le citer avoir reçu
des pressions pour intervenir dans le
dossier de votre société mcka c'est un
long litige afin et là je le cite de
priver un adversaire politique des
ressources financières qui lui donnerait
les moyens de combattre le régime lors
des élections de 2023 il parle de vous
visiblement et de quoi s'agit-il vous
savez c'est le problème
d'identiel société à moi qui aime Cesk
c'est un procès qui était ici
à Paris à la cour d'appel MCCA avait
gagné le procès à la Cour de cassation
de de
Paris et j'ai dit la démission du juge
c'est ce que nous avions condamné
ensemble avec le président Tshisekedi
l'albitraire et l'instrumentalisation de
la justice heureusement il y a encore de
personnes comme le juge va tout Benga
mais nous avons de très bons juges nous
devons laisser la justice
fonctionner convenablement dans notre
pays pourquoi les gens ne nous
respectent pas aujourd'hui
l'instrumentalisation de la de la
justice nous devons avoir une justice
indépendante et pour moi je ne veux pas
faire ma Charrière je serai candidat je
sais que ils vont encore vouloir créer
de faux dossiers on je suis habitué mais
je me défendrai je me défendrai parce
que j'ai une vision pour mon peuple mais
là là quand il parle de pression ça veut
dire quoi une pression du pouvoir sur ce
juge pour vous nuire enfin c'est de ça
qu'on parle parce que peut-être qu'il se
disent qu'en effet vous avez des
ambitions que vous venez de déclarer
mais vous savez ces ambitions j'ai ses
ambitions depuis 2000 2016 j'avais
déclaré ma candidature quand je suis
allé à l'union sacrée ce n'était pas une
plateforme électorale l'union sacrée il
n'y a pas une charte à l'union sacrée
chacun est allé pour donner un coup de
main donc je suis candidat parce que je
vois que mon pays va mal et je peux
trouver une solution pour mon pays je le
fais quand j'étais gouverneur j'ai un
bilan donc j'ai de l'expertise après 8
ans de brouille vous avez serré la main
de l'ancien président Kabila c'était en
mai dernier à l'église à Lubumbashi
alors évidemment ça a surpris tout le
monde mais maintenant que vous nous
dites que vous êtes candidat est-ce
qu'on va vers un renversement d'alliance
sur le thème tous contre shisekedi et
est-ce qu'on pourrait voir par exemple
Joseph Kabila ou plusieurs de ses
partisans à votre congrès de lundi
prochain d'ensemble pour la République
vous savez au Congrès nous allons
inviter tout le monde nous allons
inviter tout le monde au Congrès
la réconciliation avec Monsieur Kabila
c'est une réconciliation
de de
katanguay donc j'essaierai la au
président Kabila le plus important pour
nous c'est les pays c'est le Congo je
suis un chrétien qui a catholique et
j'avais serré la main et ma main était
sincère parce que nous devons voir
l'avenir en face et le plus important
pour moi ce n'est pas pour le moment
nous n'avons pas un deal pour politique
avec qui que ce soit mais le parti va
voir va voir l'organisation
c'est que nous devons considérer comme
ami et allier y compris pourquoi pas les
kabylistes vous pourriez faire alliance
avec les kabylistes vous savez pour le
moment nous avons un grand parti pour
politique nous avons notre propre vision
avec le parti pour politique pour le
moment nous marchons en tant qu'ensemble
pour la République mais quand vous dites
pour le moment ça veut dire que ça peut
changer que il peut y avoir cette main à
l'église peut devenir un alliance
politique vous le savez
il y a eu la main à l'église mais il y a
plusieurs candidats qui se sont déclarés
et je respecte tous je respecte tout le
monde mais
jusqu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas l'ordre
du jour mais justement il y a beaucoup
de candidats dans l'opposition en plus
de vous monsieur Katumbi il y a ma tata
Ponyo il y a nos Yto il y a Fayulu
pourquoi pas demain le prix Nobel de la
Paix 2018 le docteur mukue or il n'y a
qu'un seul tour dans votre pays est-ce
que cette multitude de candidats de
l'opposition ne va pas faire le jeu du
président sortant
vous savez d'abord
j'ai félicite mes frères candidats
j'espère peut-être il y aura encore une
femme qui va devenir aussi quand
candidate
si là
vous savez le grand problème que nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est les élections à
un tour le jour que j'essaie du
président de la de la République je vais
remettre les élections à deux tours donc
pour être président pour avoir la
légitimité dans notre pays il faut avoir
50 + 1 si vous avez moins de 50% vous ne
pouvez pas défendre la population
congolaise ça c'est après 2023 mais là
on parle de maintenant oui donc quand je
parle de maintenant je n'ai pas peur de
toute façon vous savez la porte est
ouverte
à tout le candidat je l'ai fait quand
j'étais à l'eau à l'opposition avec le
rassemblement à Genève la porte est
ouverte mais là j'ai un grand parti
politique je ne peux pas décider c'est
aujourd'hui je dois consulter le parti
et si le parti me donne le mandat des
négocier avec les autres c'est ce qui
serait une très bonne chose pour le pays
merci Moïse Katumbi de nous avoir
accordé cet entretien et merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis sur nos deux chaînes
France 24 et Radio France Internationale
[Musique]